if you drive a car long enough odds are
you'll end up in some sort of fender
bender which will
lead to questions about who pays for the
damages that's the topic of today's
conversation with eric palacios
in our las vegas now segment so in the
event of an accident how do you know
whether
you're going to have to pay for it your
insurance company is going to have to
pay for it or maybe somebody else's
insurance company will pay for it well
the first question is who is at fault
for the accident
if it's your fault and you have full
coverage
then your insurance company will cover
the damages
to repair your car or the full value of
it if it's
deemed a total loss you do have a
deductible however and that varies uh
according to the policy normally between
250 it could be all the way up to a
thousand dollars
the danger though for people who just
adhere to the law
enough and only have liability coverage
is if
they're in an accident and it is their
own fault they're on their own
that's true you're on your own if you
just have liability
and you cause the accident if you're
responsible for it
or the person that causes the accident
if it's somebody else's fault if they
don't have insurance
uh then usually it's on your own dime to
get the car repaired
what recourse do you have if the other
person doesn't have insurance
well if you have a full coverage then
your own insurance company
uh will step in and repair your vehicle
sometimes uh it's not clear who's at
fault and insurance companies take
days or weeks to decide uh who is at
fault and if they're going to step in
and repair it
if you can't wait for that decision to
be made even if the accident wasn't your
fault
if you have full coverage you can have
your own insurance company
repair the vehicle you will have to pay
the deductible up front
but if it's deemed to be the other
person's fault then you can get that
deductible back
insurance companies are famous for
dragging their feet when it comes to
paying for repairs because there's the
back and forth that goes on
what do people do when that happens well
you can have your own insurance company
step in and take care of it
that usually makes it go a little bit
faster if it's not your fault
uh you don't have to worry your rates
won't go up uh your insurance company
will
get the money from the insurance company
of the at fault
driver a lot of people are very hesitant
to use their own insurance
thinking that it's going to make their
premiums increase but if the accident
isn't your fault
if you're just making a claim because
there was damage uh
caused by somebody else then your
insurance will not go up
what if you feel your own insurance
company is dragging their feet and
and not paying what you feel they should
be paying for
there's different things you can do one
you can talk to an attorney uh two
if it's not to the level where you need
to involve an attorney you can write
a complaint to the nevada division of
insurance they'll investigate the matter
so there are some things that you can do
to protect yourself and get the
insurance company to act a little faster
bottom line you find people are much
better off when they are fully insured
it's always a good idea especially with
the the economy the way it is we find
a lot of drivers are out there without a
current insurance they don't pay their
premium so it's cancelled
and then uh if you are hit by one of
these drivers
you're on your own if you don't have not
just full coverage to cover your car
but also um uim which is uninsured or
underinsured motorist coverage to
protect you
in the event during an accident all
right eric always good information
thanks so much for joining us
thanks for having me you can give eric
palacios and associates a call at that
number 702-444-7777